is your mom also using at the time no
she's not a trainer and she kind of
knows that they are doing something yes
you know you're using from them she
knows that I'm like smoking pot she
doesn't know that I'm buying it there
she has a inkling that I'm smoking pot
but she's also schizophrenic so she's
all over the place like I I remember one
time we had dropped acid from from the
guy upstairs and and she was screaming
what's wrong with your eyes I can't
believe what is wrong with you and then
she just started screaming I can't
believe I'm with all these drug addicts
drug addicts alcoholic drinking and
Dennis just opened his door and said
Patty it's just acid shut the [__] up
you'd ruin anyone's trip get the [__] in
your room and I would this guy really is
an advocate of mine